foreign
welcome to another episode of Science
and Technology q a for kids and others
and I see all kinds of questions saved
up here
so let me uh dig into them so we have
one from RBS
if you ask an AI the exact same question
several times will it give the same
answer or will it change based on some
random function
so
well the different kinds of things
people have called AI over the years
that people have talked about artificial
intelligence which kind of dates back
into the mid-1950s
but the most recent kind of popular
version of AI and things like chat GPT
those are so-called large language
models are llms and let me answer for
that case
so
the what Chachi PT is doing
in all cases is you've given it some
textual prompt you've given it a certain
amount of text
and its goal is to keep filling in more
text you say uh you know give an essay
about such and such
and it will then start writing the essay
that it thinks would have been found
on some document on the web or something
where it's said at the top you know
here's write an essay about this and
then there's the result from the essay
so it's always trying to complete the
text that you kind of started it from
and uh question is well how does I let's
not talk in detail about how it does it
but essentially what's happening is that
it has been trained once
from
the content of the web and books and so
on maybe a trillion words of text it's
been kind of trained on the way humans
typically create text
and its goal is to complete text to give
it using the way humans typically write
text
but what it actually computes through
its neural net it has all these things
that represent the neural net is is is
based on kind of computing values of uh
things it has just a whole lot of
numbers it turns all the words you give
at the input it turns into numbers
numerical representations and the output
it will produce is a giant list of the
probabilities for essentially all
possible words in English actually all
possible sub word tokens in general
sometimes they're complete words like
the sometimes they're just pieces of
words for longer words but so its output
is the probabilities for essentially all
possible words
and then the question is well what that
that's its output at each step as it it
tries to complete your text and in each
step it's trying to add one more word to
the text it's produced and so what it
knows is what's the probability for that
word it adds to be any of the possible
words in English okay so then the final
question is okay you know the
probabilities for all the possible words
in English which one should you pick
so for example there will be one word
that is the most probable word to come
next and there'll be the sort of second
most probable word and so on down to the
you know fifty thousandth most probable
word okay so the way these models are
set up usually there is a parameter
called the temperature which is used to
kind of decide whether you pick the most
probable word or sometimes pick the less
than most probable word
if you use zero temperature
the way the model is defined is it will
always pick the most probable word at
every step
and actually what tends to happen is if
you do that the essays you get tend to
be kind of flat that was particularly
true you know chat gbt is based on the
GPT generative pre-training neural net
version 3.5 from open AI
um and uh
in in its case if you set it to have
zero temperature it will produce this
text that's sort of okay but it's a bit
monotonous if you go back to gpd3 in an
earlier version and you set it to zero
temperature it will often get so
monotonous that it's like exactly
repeating words and exactly repeating
sentences and it just sometimes gets
into a loop and just keeps saying the
same thing over and over again
with gpt4 even at zero temperature does
a bit better it um it's a bigger neural
net with more probabilities and and so
on in it
um it uh it doesn't tend to get quite as
monotonous but so the at zero
temperature the neural net will always
produce the same results given a prompt
given a certain input it will always
generate the succession of words that
come next will always be the same in the
typical way these things are set up as
soon as you're at non-zero temperature
that won't be the case because at as I
said zero temperature the okay working
out what the probabilities of all
possible words are that's just
determined by having all these numbers
flow through the neural net
then the question is well which word do
you actually pick well that's something
that involves
deciding uh the sort of
determining from probabilities what
you're going to pick zero temperature
you always pick the most probable word
it'll always be the same most probable
word every time you run the neural net
and you'll get the same thing every time
you run the run the network
and um
the
the thing that um
um
in if you are operating at non-zero
temperature you don't always pick the
most probable word with some probability
you pick a less than most probable word
as you increase the temperature the the
range of less probable words that you
that you sample gets bigger it's it's
it's roughly mathematically it's
determined by an exponential the
probability goes down exponentially as
you go further into the list of words
so I think the the typical chat gbt
models have a maximum temperature of two
and at a maximum temperature of two
you're going down into the not so
probable words you know you're going you
might be picking the 20th most probable
word sometimes or the tenth most
probable word or whatever if you do that
you get much Wilder text as a matter of
fact for I was literally just doing that
testing out some new technology that
we'll be announcing the next few days
um that uh uh relates to this and at
temperature two
um I think even GPT 4 is producing wild
stuff I mean it's just writing weird
things where it's just like dropping in
weird weird random words in different
places and so on it's very creative but
it's also very disorganized and so on
so zero temperature
sometimes maybe for writing like woven
language code or programming language
code or whatever zero temperature may be
a good thing to pick one of the things
that was done for chat gbt was
people played around with well what's
the best temperature to pick and a
temperature of 0.8 turned out to be the
one that seemed to give essays and so on
that were neither too boring nor too
wild now is there a sense in which that
temperature corresponds with anything
like physical temperature with molecules
bouncing around no it's just a
mathematical coincidence and one the
fact that one used an exponential
distribution like the distribution of
probabilities to find molecules with
certain energies is really coincidental
and is just a feature of the fact that
uh as sort of a certain knowledge of
statistical physics which makes one kind
of immediately start thinking of those
kinds of distributions when one's
thinking about these these sorts of
probabilities
now
in general uh that's what happens if you
have a particular neural net trained in
a particular way if you retrain the
neural nets all bets are off because the
training of a neural Nets also involves
all kinds of probabilities figuring out
which weights to use in in uh between
neurons and so on that's absolutely and
the usual way training is done that's
it's full of probabilistic it's full of
things that are just picked
probabilistically in doing that so if
you retrain the neural net you'll it
will definitely do different things it's
kind of like for a human if you if you
kind of relearn Things No Doubt the ways
those things will be encoded in your
brain are different you know I have to
tell a story I was just a few weeks ago
I happened to see a chap I've I've known
off and on for ages of philosopher named
David Chalmers who writes about
computation and its philosophical
features and about topics like free will
the question of whether what we do is
somehow determined by underlying rules
or whether what we do is somehow
something that is freely determined
under our own agency so to speak
and was having this conversation and uh
because he works on Free Will and I've
also uh written about Free Will and uh
how one can end up through computational
irreducibility in having what amounts to
behavior that is for all practical
purposes independent of underlying rules
but is nevertheless determined by them
in any case we're having this
conversation
and uh I think we both realize that
we're talking about free will and I'm
discussing computational reducibility
and he's saying in my opinion rather
mystically there is something free about
the way that we our our brains work and
it goes beyond any kind of uh underlying
rules but anyway they both realize that
actually we had essentially the exact
same conversation 30 years ago and um
it's sort of interesting that insofar as
one can think about Free Will so to
speak uh yet for us humans given the
same stimuli one will often respond in
the same way and I noticed for myself
actually that um there are cases where
I'll be uh trying to resolve some
question about some piece of technology
or some such other thing and the same
question will come up and I'll give an
answer which seems like it's an original
answer to me at that moment and somebody
will point out you said the exact same
thing two years ago when we last
discussed this
and so usually then I say good it's then
it's consistent and and probably you
know maybe it's correct maybe it's it is
might or might not be correct but at
least it's consistent
let's see
there's a question here
from knock two
do you think at any point we will create
an AI Factory like specialized AI
algorithms that create other AIS
which do well at some specific task
um
well I think there are several different
issues here
one is
given a particular like let's say a
large language model
can you create a more specialized large
language model that does well at
particular tasks I think the answer is
probably yes it has not explicitly been
done that way yet but I think it
probably will be let me explain
something about large language models
one of the surprising things about chat
GPT is that you can talk to it about all
kinds of different things sort of any
topic that's kind of out there on the
web or in books or whatever it'll be
able to yak about it
it might say things that are factually
correct it might make stuff up it might
write fiction it might write sort of
reasonable fact-ish stuff
one of the things that I certainly
notice and it's very frustrating thing
really is like I was literally just
looking at some output from gpt4 and I
look at it and it's like well yeah sure
it makes sense it seems roughly right
and then I realized actually if I look
in more detail it's not right it's very
convincing sounding but it's just not
right and in some respects it sort of
sometimes more difficult to go back from
the thing that looks convincing but
isn't right to the thing that one would
do if one just started from scratch but
any case
one can sort of talk to Chachi BT about
a whole range of topics
but one of the things that has been a
big surprise and not very well
understood is this concept of so-called
few shot learning
um where you can essentially tell it
things like
uh you know Ura
um
a a scientist from the 1600s who knows
only about the things that were known at
that time and blah blah blah
and then you can ask it questions and it
will sort of stay in character and it
will it will kind of have have organized
itself to only be using that part of its
kind of one could say knowledge base
that part of its linguistic base
that is relevant to let's say scientists
from the 1600s
how that works we don't completely know
because every time it produces a new
word
that is the next word that it's is
putting down in the essay it's creating
every time it puts down that next word
it's running through the exact same
neural network that it always does and
the fact that it had this kind of
pre-prompt
that said here's this thing you know act
like a scientist from the 1600s or
something
it's it's using that information
as part of the initial collection of
numbers as it ripples through the neural
net making each successive word but
exactly why the presence of that sort of
pre-prompt
um causes it to sort of organize itself
to only be in sort of one part of its
linguistic knowledge base nobody really
understands
um it's an important problem to to
understand better
but if you do do this sort of few shot
learning and actually in few short
learning you often also give it examples
do it like this do it like this and it
kind of gets in the groove and then will
stay in character to those examples so
to speak
one would suspect that if one has done
few shot learning for example prompting
a various kinds to get it in a Groove
that one could somehow just say Okay
chop off everything else that isn't
relevant to This Groove
one would suspect one could do that but
nobody knows how to do that yet
I think
it's a little subtle because
it's you know people used to think back
in the 1940s 50s things like that that
if you did brain surgery on human brains
and you or if somebody had some sort of
injury to their brain and some piece of
the brain was destroyed
that that would mean that there were
just certain things that person wouldn't
remember
but that isn't true what seems to be the
case is that yeah there are changes but
those changes are much more subtle and
it's not just oh I forgot everything I
knew about how to speak French or
something or some very specific kind of
content area it's not like
in well you might think that memory will
be organized in the brain with oh we've
got this section of the brain that knows
about this we've got that section that
knows about this
you might have thought that it was like
that just like you know in a library
physical Library you might have books
about this topic shelved in this place
and books about that topic shelved in
that place
I have to say now that I think about it
I haven't thought about this in years
that even for a computer
the question of where is that memory
stored
is has become a lot more subtle than it
was in the past
in the past it might have been the case
that you could readily say okay in the
memory of the computer in in the well
these days it would be many gigabytes
many billions of of characters of memory
so to speak where is the particular
memory associated with
um oh knowing some you know some
particular number or some such other
thing where is that stored in the memory
of the computer
it used to be more straightforward than
it is today if you actually look at the
memory of a computer
it will be it will be sort of uh
there'll be all these little sub pieces
of memory and they'll all be kind of
hooked together it's a complicated thing
because when you allocate memory to use
for a particular purpose in a computer
you're always the the way memory
allocate is working let me not get off
on a big Side Track about this you can
talk about it people are interested
um it isn't the case that it's just like
oh here's a big block of memory you're
going to use it for this oh there's
another program running here's a big
block of memory for that it tends to be
much more uh in sort of um in terms of
the actual memory addresses it tends to
be much more in a sense fragmented than
that
but that's even with computers when it
comes to neural Nets the question of
that fact that you just trained a neural
net on where is that fact the answer is
that fact might be distributed across a
billion different numbers that
characterize the structure of the neural
Nets and we don't really know how that
distribution across those numbers works
it seems like oh it's the third decimal
digit of this number is really important
for that oh it's this part of that
number that's really important for that
but it's the whole thing collected
together that manages to get the neural
net to kind of uh generate the results
it gets
so I do suspect that there will be a way
of saying well actually even though the
sort of the the the memory of this of
this thing is distributed uh in some
sense across the whole neural net and
all the hundreds of billions of
Connections in the neural net and so on
I think it will be possible to say let's
make something which is a smaller
version now now a thing people often do
these days is to try and distill a
neural net let's say you start off with
a neural net with 100 billion
connections
you can run lots of queries through that
neural net so you can know sort of you
you can't give a sort of mathematical
description of what the neural net does
but you can certainly say I ran a
billion queries through and this is what
each of them did and you can use that as
a way to train another neural net so
trick people are starting to use is to
say okay I've got a neural net with 100
billion connections let me see if I can
train a neural net with only 10 million
connections and see whether I can get it
to do roughly the same as the 100
billion collection neural net does and
there's reasonable success with this
another thing one can do is to make the
numbers that are specifying the the
weights and the neural net uh not be
precise you know uh 16 digit numbers but
something that is just a few digit
number
so in any case I think the answer is
that it will be possible to either sort
of find ways to sort of carve out a
piece of a big neural net and say this
is the piece that is relevant for this
purpose this is a piece that relevant is
relevant for that purpose and I think
potentially also to train smaller neural
Nets from bigger neural Nets maybe just
concentrating on queries that were
relevant to some particular topic area
now there's a quite different question
which is making a factory for physical
objects that's very much based on AI
that's been a very long story and the
factories
uh there are surprising number of things
that get done in factories even
assembling very high-tech objects like
cell phones and things like this
where it's just not worth having a robot
try and do it it's too hard to get the
robot to work and get to work
consistently it's better to have people
just do it
um it's I mean one can argue about uh
it's you know in the end it's a sort of
an economic question how much does it
cost to buy the robot versus how much do
you have to pay the people and that's a
complicated issue quite different kind
of topic but when it comes to robots
making things uh sort of AIS making
things in factories that turn out to be
very mundane issues which are really
hard like how do you pick something up
this is something that comes up a lot
for companies like Amazon which have
giant warehouses where you know the sort
of theory of Amazon is you can you can
buy anything through it well that means
those those inner things are on shelves
and warehouses and they are in all kinds
of different shapes and sizes and
something or someone has to pick them
out of the places where they're stored
and put them in the box that's going to
be shipped to to you and taking an
object of any shape and picking it up
and not breaking the object and not
dropping the object turns out to be
really hard now you know in a sense
we've cheated for ourselves because most
objects are set up most objects that one
can sort of are worth buying from you
know online
you know e-commerce type type site are
things that you would be able to pick up
if you got it they're not things where
you pick it up and it's this weird
slippery thing and it slips out of your
hands at the first moment
um they're things that were made for
humans to use so they are things which
you know work uh set up so that you know
you can with your hands with your
opposable thumb and all that kind of
thing you can pick the thing up you
don't need to be an octopus to pick it
up for example
so in a sense we humans have made things
to make it easier for ourselves to pick
things up but even if you make a robot
hand that's still you know four fingers
and a thumb and has a certain amount of
articulation it's still really hard to
get it to grasp an object and pick it up
and in fact sometimes the things that
are best at picking things up don't look
much like human hands at all
and um
this question of how do you learn how to
pick things up is something which I'm
kind of strongly suspecting is going to
be solved through things a bit like
large language models large neural Nets
and so on that that will be solved
fairly soon but that's been a big
impediment in kind of making robotic
lots of kinds of factory-like operations
I mean there's there's things where what
works pretty well is to have robots that
do a very specific very defined task
where the robot moves you know 18
centimeters this way picks up that thing
moves it 12 centimeters that way and uh
you know turns the screw to to
um uh to insert it in something those
kinds of things and then you can do a
little bit better than that by giving
the robot eyes so it can kind of
visually see oh yes did the screw get
put in the in the correct hole and so on
um in a sense
those kinds of eyes work a bit like a
control system where okay so you know if
you have a control system that's trying
to be I don't know let's say cruise
control for a car
so and cause cruise control it's like
okay normally you put on the gas a
certain amount to make the car goes up
in speed but if the car is supposed to
be going uphill you have to put the gas
on more if it's going downhill you have
to take your foot off the gas maybe you
even have to break a bit
um that in a car there is this control
system for cruise control for example if
you have Crux of control in your car and
you put it on and it says okay keep the
car going it's 60 miles an hour let's
say and then there's a giant you know
there's a very steep hill and the car
has to push the gas more and then maybe
suddenly you get to the top of the hill
and the the car would uh you don't have
to put your foot on the gas as much how
does the car not sort of start zooming
forward well the answer is it has a
controller a control system and what
it's doing is it's sensing the speed of
the car and it's saying okay the car's
going a little bit too slowly put your
foot on the gas more so to speak
automatically increase the gas so that
will make the car go a little faster and
what can happen is if you do that and
then then you say oh my gosh now I'm
going 62 miles and I'm going too fast
take my foot off the gas if things don't
work right the car will just be going
faster slower faster slower it'll be
oscillating around and that's that's
what happens if you have a controller
that isn't set up correctly
what ends up being the right way to do
it is you have a certain time delay so
you go a little bit faster but you don't
you don't kind of um uh instantly
respond to the fact you're going fast
you just you know calmly respond a
little bit and you don't you don't let
it get into that unstable oscillating
phase but that's a very typical form of
control system such Control Systems have
existed since the 1940s
um and uh there's sort of this area of
mathematical uh sort of engineering
called control theory that is all about
kind of working out when will a system
be stable when will it be unstable when
is a system controllable when is it
possible to make that car successfully
go at 60 miles an hour I mean if you
have a car that's underpowered to go up
a hill that's that steep well by golly
you won't be able to get it to go at 60
miles an hour
um and there are also questions about
whether you can maintain stability
whether the the system will always show
certain kinds of of instability and that
there are lots of control systems we see
all around us for example
thermostats for keeping temperature
constant temperature that's a very
common type of control system uh usually
the buzz term is a PID controller is a
very simple kind of controller that um
uses a certain algorithm to keep at a
fixed let's say temperature
same is true more elaborately with
autopilots for planes keeping a certain
uh heading independent of which way the
wind is is pushing the airplane and
keeping a certain altitude those are
things that are done can be done with
these sort of Fairly traditional
Electronics rather than computer-based
controllers by the way one example of a
more complicated kind of controller is
the flight controller for a drone
um where and that sort of only became
possible within the last decade to
really have uh those those controllers
are not typically done with simple
Electronics we just have a few
electronic components they're done with
a computer and the algorithms are more
complicated to make those work and fly
in a stable fashion and another famous
early controller was the automatic
windshield wiper where it was you know
only if you sort of see rain do you sort
of operate the windshield wipe it was an
early application I think of transistors
it's just I think they think the first
controller for that just had one
transistor in it whereas your average
microprocessor these days might have a
billion transistors and and to make a
computer that we have
but any case in sort of factory
automation the idea of control systems
that sort of keep things at in some
fixed way that's a that's a very old
idea uh often even Vision systems where
the robot has eyes are being used kind
of like a control system just say oh we
just need to make sure that the that the
screw goes right into that hole and we
can't you kind of oscillate on each side
and you you know put it right in
um the uh
the question of whether one can make a
kind of um
um sort of how one makes a kind of
general purpose Factory with AI it's a
difficult question I mean a typical
actual Factory even when it has lots of
robots in it it is non-trivial to
reprogram the factory it's it's gotten
better I think uh Tesla pioneered some
robotic construction techniques uh all
car companies I think at this point use
significant numbers of robots on their
production lines but if you say oh last
week we were making this kind of car
next week we want to switch to making a
completely different kind of car
bringing up the line the production line
to do something quite different has
traditionally taken a while like months
my impression is that that's time has
gotten down considerably but it's not
like you just tell the robots I think uh
okay just reconfigure yourselves to make
you know here let me show you this new
car assembly that we're going to make
let me show you the instruction book now
reconfigure yourselves to operate
according to this instruction book that
hasn't yet become a fast thing to do
that will come I mean one of the things
that is totally remarkable about llms is
you can actually give them things like
instruction books and have them read the
instruction book and sort of figure out
what to do from that now they don't
necessarily do it completely reliably so
you have to have all kinds of safety
nets and checks to make sure the thing
didn't just go crazy and have a little
brain glitch so to speak that caused it
to just do something do something quite
wrong
um but I think it's the thing that will
be a definitely a coming thing that one
will be able to basically say I want to
make this
here's the manual for how to make this
or even just here's the here's the thing
that's been made uh you know go ahead
and and put it together you know I don't
think I've ever seen a demo yet of
something like a Lego construction where
you know you have all these pictures of
how the Lego books put together and um
um I find them hard to follow often but
that's just me
um but then to be able to have an AI
system that can just read those
instructions understand the pictures put
the Legos together that's step one step
two is just look at the picture on the
box of the final completed thing and
figure out how to put how to take the
components you have and put them
together to make that thing that will
come I'm guessing that's that's not that
far away a couple of years maybe
um to be able to do things like that and
that will certainly help in making sort
of more robotic AI enabled factories
let's see
uh
looking at some of the questions that
have come in about this particular point
so spare parts is asking any thoughts on
using physics simulations versus the
real world to teach robots
you know
people there's this technique called
reinforcement learning which is actually
kind of related to feedback control
systems that I was just talking about
they've got a lot of the same
mathematics they grew up in two slightly
different communities and so they have a
lot of different language which is super
confusing to people
um uh because you see things which are
like very similar but not quite the same
described in quite different ways but
you know one of the ideas of
reinforcement learning is you've got
this robot and it can try things in the
real world and see what happens and use
that as its way to train itself about
how things should work in a sense that's
what we humans might do when we first
learn to you know use our hands or
something and yes you know you stick
your thumb somewhere near your mouth and
eventually you discover this is how to
put your thumb in your mouth or whatever
um and uh that's something which you
kind of learn by experience interesting
things in the world quotes robotically
so that's one approach
um if you are sort of making a
self-driving car do its thing you can
say well let's try it on this kind of
Road let's try it in the snow let's try
it in this case in that case
that's sort of one possibility the other
possibility is to essentially make a
video game type environment where you
are supposedly successfully simulating
what the self-driving car would do what
what its environment would be and what
its mechanical response would be to
what's going on and then train it that
way
what's tended to happen is that it's
just much cheaper to run endless video
game like simulations for training than
it is to train anything in the real
world where things are sort of where a
robot is actually walking around and
banging into things and and bashing its
head and having to be replaced and this
foot falls off and you have to replace
it that's all a big pain relative to
just having the thing existence on
virtualized game environment it's sort
of interesting that when we talk when we
talk about educating humans about things
there are lots of purposes where it
seems much better to just do it in the
real world than to experience it in
virtual world but the thing about it is
that's because we're sort of tuned to
deal with the real world experience
things at the speed that the real world
happens whereas if you are training in
AI the AI could be running at sort of a
thousand times real world speed
um training itself against many many
more scenarios now that's all well and
good so long as the simulation is
accurate enough that you are capturing
what you need to capture if you train
the self-driving car based on a model of
snow and it's not how snow actually
works then it's going to have learned
the wrong thing it's also the case I
think that a lot of that training is
probably in the end going to be
unnecessary because what's happening is
one's just getting the AI to basically
learn certain rules about the laws of
physics and things like this which you
could if you were able to deal with it
differently just say these are the laws
of physics they're described by these
equations or rules or whatever else and
but because you're saying everything's
going to be learned by a neural net the
neural net doesn't have any way to
directly solve equations or whatever
else so you have no choice but to just
say learn by example learn by example
learn by example whereas if you could
combine that with something which was
just using kind of mathematical science
or something to just solve the equations
you wouldn't have to go through all that
training and that's a powerful direction
that one's just starting to figure out I
mean a lot of things we've done with for
example the Wolfram plug-in for chat GPT
is an example of kind of combining the
ability to do sophisticated computation
with the pure sort of linguistic and
Common Sense kinds of capabilities of an
llm and I think that will be
increasingly a story of knitting
together kind of deep computation and in
a sense scientific knowledge of the
world together with this kind of learn
by example type thing
um
a quick question here from Pedro is that
computer power then that speeds real
progress
in for example llms AIS things like this
so you know I think I mentioned this
here before
the story of neural networks is is such
a strange story in the history of
Science and Technology because neural
Nets sort of modeled on how brains how
we think brains work but they were kind
of defined back in the 1940s
and you know at that time people would
say we've got a few neurons five neurons
at most that we set up with an electric
circuit and so on and then now in kind
of chat GPT there are many millions of
neurons with hundreds of billions of
connections between the neurons it's a
very big thing
and
the fact that in chat gbt we got
something that can meaningfully write
essays and so on and at what point how
many neurons do we have to have to make
that work nobody knew and even beyond
that there were other things that were
done that were very much sort of
engineering Solutions of okay yes you
can get you know a chat gbt like system
to complete sentences that you start and
so on but but it will go off track it
will lose its train of thought it will
do all kinds of crazy things what was
important there was that it was trained
using reinforcement learning with human
feedback to kind of stay on track you
know yes you're writing a poem this is
how poems work yes you're writing an
essay this is what to expect yes don't
produce all kinds of uh crazy bad words
when you respond to something and the
way that was done it's a little bit like
a robot learning things in the real
world what was done one was that
a sort of prototype of chat gbt was put
out there in the wild well not quite in
the wild but people were brought in to
say okay go have a chat with this thing
and tell it comment tell it yes that was
a good piece of chat no that was a bad
piece of chat here's what was wrong with
that here's a piece you should take out
here's a piece you should add to give
that kind of feedback and that was
turned out to be I think more crucial
than people even recognize yet so the
fact that chat gbt actually worked in a
useful way that kind of Direction human
Direction so-called reinforcement
learning human feedback rlhf
um that those steps were more important
than people expected it's kind of an
interesting thing because in a sense the
the people who first did that kind of
human feedback for chat gbt their views
about the world were in a sense burnt
into the very first versions of chat GPD
so it had all kinds of political views
and this and that now because that just
happened to me the views of the fairly
small number of people who did that
reinforcement training uh subsequently
it sort of got more more generic size by
having more people and and be it by
being specifically sort of trained to
not go in the specific directions of the
people who first trained it but it kind
of gives one an idea of kind of the the
role of training and and the role of
sort of how do you govern the AIS well
you know you imagine you've got people
feeding in these prompts giving these
reinforcement training to the AIS and
you know I think it's an interesting
question sort of how do you do
government democracy whatever in the
land in the time of AIS and you can sort
of imagine it's just all the people in
the world provide reinforcement training
all the people in the world or in a
country or whatever or in some
particular Community provide essentially
prompts to the AI to tell it what they
want it to do each one telling it maybe
pulling it in a different direction then
it's up to the AI to figure out how to
sort of merge those together a
challenging even philosophically sort of
impossible thing to do
let's see
um
look at something somewhat different
here
uh
keflas is asking what do you think about
sources of energy now and in the future
or developed and developing countries
um
the
uh interesting question so I mean
I I get exposed to a certain amount to
this because I know a lot of people who
are interested in what usually gets
called Deep Tech
which is uh kinds of Technology problems
which would be very important if they
were solved and but they're hard to
solve and so energy generation is one of
them
so I mean if we look at what's available
now well you know there's a lot of
energy that's that's sort of uh uh
provided to us by all those trees that
existed in the Carboniferous period and
turned into into oil and so on crushed
underground and that's been for the last
hundred years or so that's been a big
source of of energy in the world then
there are things where you know there's
hydroelectric energy where you're
basically using the fact that you've got
water I mean people used even before
electricity people had water Mills where
they would just use the flow of water
um in a river to determine to to run a a
a wheel to to produce energy but the
fancier version of that is to put a dam
in and to have water sort of water high
water on one side and low water on the
other side and as the water runs through
the dam it runs through electric General
creators that um it the the flow of
water spins around the the wheels in
those electric generators and generates
electricity I mean it should be said
that the vast majority of energy that
people I would say care
well is this really true yeah I think
the most convenient form of energy is
probably electrical energy people find
it much more convenient to sort of
package things up as electrical energy
in batteries or on electric power lines
than to have other forms of energy now
there are other things I mean you can
have uh you know gas for example natural
gas and you can just burn it directly to
produce heat
um but electricity has been a very
flexible way of of uh of of storing
transporting uh having energy ready to
be used in different ways to make light
to make heat to run computers to run uh
to to drive
um mechanical things and so on it's a
very conveniently convertible form of
energy so a lot of types of energy
Generation
Um involve electricity
so the question is then how do you get
electricity what's what are some good
ways to get electricity well you'll
you'll need some kind of energy that you
can turn into electrical energy so you
know hydroelectric energy dams
geothermal energy
um
the idea of geothermal energy well
there's different kinds there's there's
kind of
um shallow geothermal energy and there's
deep geothermology the Deep one is
probably the most interesting case
um that uses the fact that the center of
the earth is really hot compared to the
surface the average temperature you know
a little bit under the surface is like
50 degrees Fahrenheit
um the temperature of the center of the
earth is many thousands of degrees
Fahrenheit there's there's partly
there's just Relic heat from when the
Earth was created 4.6 billion years ago
that's been kind of locked into the
insides of the earth about half the heat
of the earth and the other half comes
from the decay of radioactive elements
inside the earth
um producing uh producing nuclear
turning nuclear energy into heat
so the way that deep geothermal energy
works is you uh it's a little bit like
the way that you might drill for oil you
drill down until you get a deposit oil
now you're just drilling down anywhere
on the earth and you drill a mile or two
down and a mile or two down it's pretty
hot you're getting closer to the center
of the earth below them below the the
crust of the earth which is like 50
miles thick there's this um you go you
go into the mantle of the earth which is
sufficiently hot but the rock is liquid
there eventually you get to the center
of the Earth where it's solid again
because of the pressure is is preventing
it from becoming liquid but um the uh so
anywhere on the earth you drill down you
know a mile or two down and it's really
hot it's certainly hot enough to boil
water
and so then the idea is you put sort of
you you you go you drill down you pump
water down or some other fluid down on
one side at the bottom of your your big
uh well the water gets really hot
because the Earth is really hot there
and then you pump it back up and you
take that the water that you just heated
and you use that to uh to drive to make
a kind of a uh to drive an electric
generator for example it's a general
principle that you can
use heat to make things like electric
power uh heat there's a bunch of
molecules running around a kind of a
random way and each the molecules
individually have lots of energy
associated with them but the heat heat
is a sort of disorganized form of energy
and something was figured out in the
early 1800s was the idea that in order
to make use of heat you kind of have to
have sort of a hot thing and a cold
thing and in a sense the the way that
you make use of heat is by having a flow
of heat from a hot thing to a cold thing
so there's there's sort of always a hot
Reservoir and a cold Reservoir so in the
case of geothermal energy what's
happening is you start off with the
water or whatever it is usually people
talk about using things other than water
um high pressure methane maybe is I
forget uh some some high pressure gas I
think is better than than water or steam
um uh yeah there's a the um
you um uh no it's not methane it's
another I I've forgotten
um in any case the the um you uh
um you're kind of it's cold at the top
you pump it down you get it really hot
and then you bring it back up again and
then you're kind of getting a flow of
heat from the hot to the cold and using
that to drive something that can can
make for example electricity
so what are some other ways to make
energy
um another way well another thing you
can try to use to make energy is like
the tides
um the uh the the effect of the Moon
pulling the water on the earth in sort
of the direction of the Moon and away
from the directional moon on the
opposite side of the earth uh there are
the the you know the water goes up and
down you can potentially use that like a
sort of uh a daily version of a
hydroelectric Dam doesn't seem to work
that well
um another big thing you can use is wind
uh that's why there are wind turbines
all over the place
um I'm not sure how terrific that that
source of energy really is
um I mean it it uh the wind turbines are
extremely expensive to make
um and uh uh it is the case that there
is the the rotation of the Earth
does uh and and also the um uh the fact
that hot air rises and so on those
effects together produce flows of air on
the earth that are wind and uh there are
plenty of places where there's lots of
wind
um and particularly over oceans and
things where the wind is not stopped by
it by by um uh features on the on the
earth and so on there's there's plenty
of wind and so long as you don't have
too many wind turbines all lined up
behind each other where one of them is
kind of stopping the Wind by you know
the wind is is used to turn the turbine
but that's slowing down the wind and
then you have another turbine that's uh
sort of in the shadow of that one so
long as you don't do that there's sort
of enough wind to go around
uh my impression is that a lot of these
methods of energy generation very
detailed thing whether uh whether it
really you know how much does it cost to
construct the wind turbine how does it
much does it cost to maintain the wind
turbine all those kinds of things
I mean a very important feature of
things like wind and and uh geothermal
energy and so on is that they it's not
going to run out you know until I
suppose if we if we try to extract
enough energy from the earth we might be
able to slow its rotation down but you
know we humans are just so unbelievably
far away from from doing something like
that it's we're much further away from
doing that by Pruitt could probably work
out how many hours of magnitude compared
to uh sort of using up all of the oil or
natural gas that got sort of uh created
a few hundred million years ago
um when trees were first on the land and
and
um uh sort of collecting energy from
sunlight and then getting fossilized and
turning into into things like oil and so
on
um so you know all of these things
eventually uh the the energy
eventually you take all these sort of
forms of organized energy and eventually
you turn them into what to us seems like
disorganized energy namely heat but in
the case of like slowing down the
rotation of the earth it's just not not
even close I mean in in um to the kind
of thing that that we could achieve
so
other forms of energy another big one is
photovoltaics which is taking uh the
light from the sun
um and uh turning that into electricity
and it turns out to be possible using
semiconductors to directly turn uh using
the the photoelectric effect the fact
where you can have a photon of light
come in and it can make an electron it
can take an electron that was otherwise
just happily hanging around some atoms
it can kind of make that electron turn
into something that makes an electric
current
um it's been a very challenging thing to
figure out how to make efficient
photovoltaic cells uh you see these big
solar Farms so to speak with um usually
purple blackish type um uh silicon
um
uh uh solar cells and um uh the
efficiency of those things is just not
all that great
um and if if somebody could discover
some new kind of compounds some new
material for which photons from the Sun
are the energy that protons come in from
the Sun hitting it produces more
electricity it's certainly possible that
that could happen there's nothing that
that is sort of a physical limitation on
the efficiency of those things and that
would have a dramatic effect
um
on on how effective that how effectively
that works
so another big area of energy generation
is nuclear energy of which there are
really two kinds fission energy infusion
energy uh fission energy comes from the
breaking up a very large nuclei like
uranium and plutonium
and fusion energy comes from the the
pushing together of small nuclei like
hydrogen it's just a feature of nuclear
physics that both of those activities
make energy both breaking apart a big
nucleus and to make smaller nuclei and
putting together small nuclei to bigger
nuclei you might say well what's the
what's the nucleus that everybody wants
to be it's iron 56 that's the type of
nucleus that has sort of the um that has
is the most tightly bound nucleus it's
the one where if you you know break
apart uranium eventually you'll get down
to that put together hydrogen eventually
you'll get to that that's why for
example the crust of a neutron star is
probably made of iron 56 for that reason
but in any case the the um so in fission
energy what you're starting off with is
uranium which you mine from the ground
and very conveniently the half-life the
time for the decay of uranium is in the
in billions of years a couple a billion
years so there's still uranium that was
created when the Earth was created was
created by nuclear processes and stars
and it was kind of locked in on the
earth and it can be mined and it's still
radioactive and that's kind of the thing
you start from in making a nuclear
reactor now there are many different
layers of what happens there you can
make you can make a nuclear reactor make
new radioactive elements that you can
then use in a nuclear reactor so-called
breeder reactors and there are a whole
variety of different methods for for
doing
um
for using uh for using that but but
essentially a nuclear reactor is uh is
making heat from the fact that there are
uh uranium
um okay so so the way a nuclear reactor
works is a uranium nucleus
spontaneously breaks apart at some rate
the rate is quite low because it takes a
couple of the half if you have a big
lump of uranium 235 a particular isotope
with uranium with um total of 235
protons and neutrons in it with that
type of uranium there's a different
isotopic uranium-238 which is stable
doesn't occur at all but uranium-235
which you can separate out with great
effort using things like centrifuges
um you separate it out it's then
radioactive it decays it decays by
spontaneous fission that means that
basically the uranium nucleus you know
after a billion years or so just boom it
falls apart
and when it falls apart it produces a
bunch of neutrons among other things and
those neutrons have quite high energy
and the thing that leads to a so-called
chain reaction is that once one uranium
nucleus falls apart it produces neutrons
that then hit other uranium nuclei they
poke other uranium nuclei and that poke
causes those other uranium nuclei to
fall apart then they produce neutrons
then those neutrons go and make other
uranium nuclei fall apart and you have
this Chain Reaction where you have more
and more and more neutrons produced more
and more and more uranium nuclei
produced it goes exponentially
um in in that way if you want to make a
nuclear weapon that's what you want to
have happen is to have that Chain
Reaction happen as quickly as possible
and produce as much energy as possible
if you make a nuclear reactor you have
to have so-called control rods or
moderator and what the control rods do
or the moderator does is it absorbs
neutrons so all these neutrons are being
produced but you want just the right
number of neutrons to be sort of freely
flowing around that it makes a bunch of
other uranium nuclei kind of
explode just enough to make the power
you want but not so much that the whole
thing's going to go out of control so
you know typically in a nuclear reactor
there'll be these control rods that are
that are pushed inside the core of the
nuclear reactor and you kind of pull
them out as you pull the control rods
out the neutrons can flow freely and so
there are sort of more neutrons there
you push the control rods in they absorb
the neutrons and the thing sort of calms
down so to speak and again it's one of
these control systems that typically
operates you know how far out should the
should the control rods be what
temperature should the in the core of
the reactor be when things go very wrong
the core of the reactor's so-called
melts down which means that it gets so
hot that it becomes molten and that's
very bad because the the nuclear reactor
was engineered by to be a solid nuclear
reactor of a certain shape it wasn't
energy had to turn into a pile of liquid
liquid uranium or something and that's
happened a few times in the history of
nuclear power and it's very bad
but um
in any case so nuclear reactors have
this feature you still have to mine
uranium but you don't need very much of
it at all to to to uh produce a great
deal of power and you can also make your
own fuel for a nuclear reactors from
nuclear reactors themselves what's
difficult is
sort of it's all a bit you know it can
be a bit dangerous the um uh you have to
engineer it to be so that nothing could
possibly go wrong but the level of of
nothing possibly going wrong usually the
the tolerances for the engineering are
maybe a factor of two have nothing going
wrong whereas I don't know you make a
plane or something it's more like a
batch of 10 I think so to to have it
takes some effort and then you have to
make these um
um uh you it it requires a lot of
Maintenance of a nuclear reactor for
example the fact that there's all this
radiation all these all these fast
particles going around you know when you
have a metal
container for the nuclear reactor that
metal is continually being damaged by
all these particles hitting it and so
that's something you have to deal with
and and uh and eventually replace and a
lot of nuclear reactors are getting into
the 50 years old and more kind of time
frame and some of them wasn't expected
they would keep working this long as it
was thought radiation damage and so on
would stop them working but there are
new designs of nuclear reactors so for
example one I was just hearing about is
well what about if you put the nuclear
reactor deep down in the ground you know
a mile down or something like that then
um the uh then even if something goes
wrong it's not really a big deal because
gosh there are deposits of uranium down
in the ground which are also radioactive
and so on and even if there was a
nuclear explosion a mile down you
wouldn't even notice I don't think you'd
even I think actually a good question
whether uh what kind of a little
earthquake that would produce a mile
down I I'm
skeptical it would be much of an
earthquake you probably it'd probably
have some effect but not much
um the the amount yeah particularly if
it was an actual nuclear explosion a lot
of nuclear tests were done underground
um not terribly deep underground and uh
they certainly you know they made little
earthquake like things but they're not
very impressive earthquakes
um and uh you know an actual earthquake
releases a lot more energy even than a
nuclear explosion
so
okay so that's on that side of of um uh
nuclear energy the fission side there's
also the fusion side people have been so
the sun is powered by nuclear fusion
hydrogen atoms hydrogen nuclei uh being
going so fast that they fuse together
they they're going so fast because in
the in the center of the sun it's 10
million degrees centigrade and that
means that the that they're going really
fast and they have to be going fast
because you have two hydrogen nuclei the
two protons protons are particles that
electrically repel each other and that
means that when two protons get close
usually they would just sort of bounce
off but if they're going fast enough
they get over that repulsion and they
get to the point where they stick
together and eventually make a helium
nucleus
um and so that process when when they do
that they release a bunch of energy
that's all really good and uh you all
you have to feed in is a bunch of
hydrogen plus a very high temperature
the problem is the following in the case
of the sun the sun is held together by
gravity and there's uh nuclear processes
going on throughout the Sun so to speak
um if you just want one of these things
in your backyard you have to make
something that's sort of as hot as as
somewhere inside the Sun and you have to
make sure that the plasma the sort of
the gas with all its electrons stripped
off that you get at very high
temperatures is is just kept confined
enough that the protons can actually run
into each other and the thing doesn't
just get so hot that it sort of you know
just gets out of everything in the case
of the sun it's all held together by
gravity throughout the whole Sun but in
the case of just a little thing in your
backyard you have to kind of keep
something at tamel and degrees
Centigrade well how do you keep anything
at 10 million degrees Centigrade you
know the the if you have I don't know a
Tungsten you know some some material
that uh can withstand high temperatures
it um uh the um uh the maximum you're
going to be able to get up to is a few
thousand degrees
um you're certainly are not going to get
to 10 million degrees so the only way
you can sort of keep things bottled up
at 10 million degrees is to use
something other than a material
container and so what gets used are
magnetic fields
um and that leads to this idea of uh
plasma confinement Fusion where you are
kind of um
uh you're trying to keep this plasma at
10 million millions of degrees
Centigrade you're trying to keep it
confined and there are these different
very elaborate kind of shapes to a very
common tokamax and stellarators are
these very weird shapes of magnets that
try to keep the this uh this plasma sort
of all bottled up to the point where you
can get a release of um of energy from
from the protons running into each other
and recently in a slightly different way
with lasers there was an example of
being able to release more energy than
you put in a nuclear fusion but there's
been it's been a long-running story when
I was a kid people said it's just around
the corner you know uh nuclear
um
nuclear fusion power will be here uh you
know in just a few years in the early
1960s well it's still not here and it's
turned out to be a very difficult
problem to confine these these plasmas
now
there are just recently last three four
five years there's been a lot of
interest in doing this a lot of a lot of
companies started uh some of them with
different ideas about how to do it
different configurations the magnetic
field different materials to make the
magnets to have things associated with
magnets and so on different computer
control systems for the magnetic fields
all those kinds of things all in an
effort to make fusion power which if it
works will be just great because it's
some something where there's no lack of
raw materials you just have to have
hydrogen
and then
uh it's sort of free Power for the world
now there are a few other things on the
horizon I mean there are a few
um less common cases so one of them is a
so-called cold fusion
so this was uh the the sort of hot
Fusion is what happens in the sun
happens in these various devices people
are trying to build and that involves
you've got all these protons in there
you know millions of degrees centigrade
and they're going fast enough they're
just going to fuse with each other
but there's the possibility that Fusion
might be achieved some other way without
making everything very hot and about
true when was it 30 years ago
um there was a claim that
cold fusion was possible
and um that in particular uh an element
called Palladium
um was sort of a big part of that and
Palladium turns out to absorb hydrogen
it dissolves hydrogen hydrogen uh in
Palladium so Palladium you have this
metal thing and you start putting
hydrogen into it and it just keeps on
packing in protons keeps on packing in
hydrogen nuclei you can just keep
putting in tons and tons of hydrogen and
the hydrogen kind of Finds Its way in
between the atoms of Palladium and so on
and somehow a piece of Palladium will
just absorb a huge amount of hydrogen so
the thought went well maybe it absorbs
so much hydrogen that just by its
crystal lattice by putting those those
uh those hydrogen atoms in this crystal
lattice you can pack them in so much
that eventually they'll sort of get
close enough that Fusion can occur
and at the time people claimed this a
bit and then people claimed it wasn't
true and there was a big sort of flap
about it and the end result was people
sort of stopped really working on that
but there'd been a small number of
groups around the world that have
continued to work on Cold Fusion it
became kind of a a oh no that can't
possibly work it's it's nonsense and it
must be a fake experiment if you're
finding that it works
um my own guess is that something like
that will work in the end how it will
work why it will work I'm not sure we
know but I think the very fact that you
can just pack so many hydrogen atoms
into some of these materials and they're
kind of arranged in this crystal lattice
um it it's kind of makes one think that
somehow it will be possible to get them
to be sort of close enough sort of
maintained by the crystal lattice that a
fusion process could occur don't know
how I don't know when if that worked it
would again be a very exciting kind of
free Power for the world type type of uh
type of story
I think the thing to realize is oh
there's just a lot of features of
materials were things are happening at a
much different scale than you expect
like when you tear something when you
break a piece of metal or chalk or
something like this you might say well
it just breaks but it turns out there's
enough energy in the breaking of some of
the atomic bonds that you produce a tiny
flash of light you even produce x-rays
when you just break something not many
but there are very high energies
associated with just Atomic bonds
um in in just your average material
I think um
in uh it's also worth saying that the
theoretical deduction of what should in
principle be possible to do with respect
to Fusion cold fusion and so on there's
no way one's going to be able to work
that out theoretically I mean if one's
very lucky one will get it but I think
it's not likely similar to the way
people are pushing towards higher
temperatures superconductors higher
temperature materials where you have
perfect electrical connection really
nobody knows how to make even the The
Fairly high temperature superconductors
that are known and by fairly high
temperature I mean the temperature of
liquid air or something
um which is not that pot so to speak
it's pretty cold
um the uh even knowing how those kinds
of superconductors work is beyond what's
been successfully figured out in physics
and to be able to predict correctly oh
we're going to have a superconductor
that will work at like say room
temperature it's it's much more likely I
think to be found empirically maybe with
some indications from Theory than
otherwise now you know I'll mention a
few other sort of other power
opportunities
another one is how do plants work well
plants take in sunlight and they sort of
effectively use that to produce energy
in some sense and they do that using
chloroplasts which contain the the
protein chlorophyll and chlorophyll
absorbs a photon and somehow and
produces uh uh sort of generates does
things with electrons eventually to
generate something which can be used to
sort of have organized energy in the
plant that organized energy in the
plants is what got bottled up so to
speak a few hundred million years ago
and turned into oil it's also what makes
you know would be worth burning and
things like this but in general the um
uh the point is if you could have your
own sort of artificial chlorophyll
artificial chloroplast that will be
another potential way to sort of make
energy from sunlight sunlight is a very
very large source of energy you know the
sun however much sunlight we use we're
not going to have the sun go out as a
result of it
um
let's see oh yes there are all kinds of
schemes for different sorts of things I
think there's one
a friend of mine is doing that uh for
portable tax
this is an idea
where light from the sun has a certain
distribution of wavelengths
and uh the photons from the Sun are not
specifically tuned they have a whole
distribution of wavelengths they're like
white light like a if you put slight
from the Sun through a prism you'll see
that it's broken into you know all the
all the colors of the rainbow
well what if you just make light
at a particular frequency a particular
wavelength can you make a more efficient
converter from light to electricity than
a general uh
photoelectric effect thing and the
answer seems to be potentially yes and
that's very interesting because if you
can increase the efficiency that's a way
of increasing the efficiency not by
virtue of changing the photovoltaic
substance but by changing the incoming
light and you can make light of a fixed
frequency uh with by essentially just
using heat
um with uh
um
with the emission lines from gases for
example that um where the the
um uh the gas will emit light at a
particular frequency and then you kind
of turn that into electricity so that's
an example of one
um
uh question being asked what will happen
when oil runs out will there be a shift
to clean energy well before this happens
uh I'm sure the answer is yes you know I
remember back 25 years ago 30 years ago
I would talk to people who are in the
geology business and I would say how
much oil is there on the Earth
and they would say well
uh eventually they would say
look it just depends how much you're
prepared to spend to get it out
the amount the total amount of oil
that exists somewhere under the surface
of the Earth is huge sometimes it's in
little pieces and rocks and you have to
do you know fracking to get it out
sometimes it's in giant reservoirs
sometimes it's very deep sometimes it's
in very inconvenient places under the
ocean all these kinds of things but
there was a there was a period of time
when people said the oil is just going
to run out there's just not going to be
enough oil on the Earth
and I think that just turned out not to
be true it just turned out there were
more and more places that oil could be
found it was just a question of they
were in very inconvenient places and it
became more and more expensive and
energy consuming to actually mine the
oil out so I don't think I'm I'm
skeptical that it will run out the
economically accessible oil that can be
uh mined out at a reasonably low price
that might run out
um but you know it's just a question of
price as soon as that's running out and
you still need it the price will go up
to the point where it becomes worthwhile
to get that oil out as well
I think the uh uh
you know there's been this big push for
all kinds of different reasons I mean
one reason is that the economically
accessible oil is certainly not equally
distributed on the surface of the Earth
there are you know particular countries
that lucked out in terms of having sort
of easy to access oil oil resources and
that's led to all kinds of effects and
the kind of uh
so the political economy of the world so
to speak
um and uh
I think
that it tends to be the case that these
other forms of energy are a bit more
kind of globally accessible I mean
there's sunlight almost everywhere yes
it you know if you're above the Arctic
Circle or something then for half the
year you don't get to have sunlight and
you don't get to operate photovoltaic
cells it tends to be the case that for
example who people who think about high
altitude drones that would be flying at
sixty thousand feet and just keep flying
continuously powered by sunlight there's
a pretty sharp cutoff that above a
certain North a certain Northern or
Southern latitude
um you just can't fly a thing with a
certain efficiency I'm above 50
something degrees north latitude I think
the things you can make these days just
can't keep themselves Aloft just at
least at least in one design
um by by using the current efficiency of
photovoltaics
um and so there are limitations there
there are places that have more wind
there are places that have geothermal
energy because they're on um uh for
example plate boundaries where yes there
are earthquakes and geysers and things
like that but there's also geothermal
energy
um there's places where you can readily
make a dam in a river and have
hydroelectric energy
Etc there are also places where there's
uh there's a limited number of places on
the Earth where uranium is is economical
to mine but as I said you don't need a
lot of your of radioactive uranium to
get started on this sort of cycle of
making nuclear fuel
so uh I think that that's some
uh yeah that's the way that works
um
well there's a question here
about nuclear energy do the dangers
nuclear energy pose a problem or do the
pros outweigh the cons
um
in the situation uh
you know
the nuclear reactors as they're
currently built are very complicated
things
and
complicated sort of one-off Engineering
Systems are hard to get precisely right
the number of nuclear accidents that
have occurred in the history of nuclear
power is not that large
it's basically let's see I can probably
even list them all 1956 wind scale in
England
uh 19
70 something Three Mile Island in
Pennsylvania
uh
1980 mid-1980s Chernobyl in Soviet Union
and then Fukushima in Japan about a
decade ago I think those are the and
each one happened in a different way for
different reasons
um
it's really hard to work out what will
happen if something goes wrong you know
I remember to tell a little historical
story for for me back in the in the
early 1980s people were very keen to
sort of push the idea of nuclear power
and to prove that the current designs of
reactors were you know 100 safe always
always hard to prove something's 100
safe
but one of the things that had happened
at the wind scale accident in England is
that radioactive gas was released into
the atmosphere not much but enough
and um a Three Mile Island
uh Radioactive gas was not released into
the atmosphere the um the the the
accident was was contained so to speak
um and so there was an effort to sort of
prove it was all going to work and I
remember
uh I was
I think probably all the people involved
in this in this story uh except for
myself happily are now dead but but um
the uh
um was the sort of effort to um uh
sort of prove the safety of nuclear
reactors by by showing new designs
couldn't possibly fail and there was
some big commission that was being put
together to show that and at that time
uh I was much younger than I am now but
I knew quite a bit about sort of
computer simulations of things and so
the theory was oh we're going to do a
computer simulation of this nuclear
reactor I'm going to prove that nothing
could possibly go wrong
and I was like that's never going to
work you know you're never going to be
able to say you know you can you can
look at certain scenarios and things but
you're never going to be able to say
nothing could possibly go wrong so I
said okay I'm not going to be involved
in this so then a few years went by and
then the Chernobyl nuclear accident
happened and I so I asked people who've
been involved in this thing so you know
if you were like nothing could possibly
go wrong a lot did go wrong at Chernobyl
and it did release radioactive gas into
the atmosphere and so on and you know
how did that happen and the answer was
well it was a Soviet reactor and it had
a bad design Etc et cetera et cetera and
the American ones are much better
probably true
Etc et cetera Etc but you know and and I
mean Chernobyl was a very famous
accident in the sense that um
oh gosh it it just produced so much a
lot of mess I remember I visited
Northern Sweden
um a couple of months after Chernobyl
happened and there was a whole big plume
of radioactive gas that had been blown
by the wind or actually radioactive dust
had been blown by the wind and that
caused uh a lot of radioactivity in the
food chain and the reindeer were you
know radioactive and it's just a huge
mess
um the uh
the actual things that happened there
um it was a failure of the control
system of Chernobyl and this whole
business about control rods and whether
the control rods can be pulled out and
pushed in and all this kind of thing one
of the things that's famous for its sort
of uh engineering issue was you know
you'll have a big system like a nuclear
reactor and they'll have warning lights
and things go wrong it's kind of like a
red warning light will come on but you
have a big complicated nuclear reactor
there's an array of a thousand warning
lights
and what had happened was that oh the
thing was a bit old and it was a bit you
know sort of crotchety and so on and it
was always running with lots and lots of
warning lights on
and you know I I often use this this
example because it's really worthwhile
you know if you have a program and it's
producing error messages and things you
really want it to run with no error
messages not just a few error messages
that you don't understand but no error
messages partly because when you have a
few and then you have a few extra ones
you don't even notice the extra ones and
that's kind of what happened at
Chernobyl is that well it was always
running with a certain number of warning
lights but then it had more warning
lights and then well then what happened
was an explosion happened and then the
whole thing was full of warning lights
um but I think even before that had
happened I don't remember the precise
details of what what occurred but it was
at a weekend I think and um it was all a
bit of a mess in terms of the chain of
command and you know people calling
people and not being able to get anybody
on the phone to say what do I do with
you know the operators of the nuclear
reactor were saying you know oh there's
this extra warnings that are on what do
we do about this
Etc et cetera et cetera but in any case
I think uh with nuclear reactors there
are lots of new designs that are uh very
different I really kind of like this
design I just heard about that involves
burying the nuclear reactor deep
underground that seems like pretty good
idea it seems like a that's one of these
uh really there's not a lot one can see
going wrong
um uh famous last words but I I think
that one seems very well contained
um but uh I mean I my own guess is that
um
um uh you know nuclear power is probably
a pretty good idea I mean it really
depends it depends on how careful you're
prepared to be
and how careful you're going to insist
on being because if you insist on being
so so careful that everything is you
know 50 times over engineered it will
never be cost effective if you say a
factor of two over engineered
um you know maybe that works but then
you have to kind of not do anything kind
of you know not miss things that um uh
uh you know not make mistakes so to
speak and
um it's you know there are challenges
there
um
I feel it it's interesting spare parts
is commenting the death rate for nuclear
energy is around point zero four deaths
per terawatt hour which is similar to
wind and solar yeah well I don't know
about solo I don't know how I mean with
wind turbines uh definitely bad for
birds and bad for humans who try and
maintain wind turbines because they're
awfully you know it's awfully high off
the ground
um the uh
um
I'm not sure what goes wrong with with
solar I mean maybe
you have these things where you're
collecting a bunch of solar energy and
things get really hot I'm not sure I
mean maybe
um uh you know somebody falls off a roof
when they're installing some solar thing
um
the uh uh Haley is commenting nuclear is
safer than coal because people are more
cautious when the stakes are higher
that's that's an interesting claim
um I think
um
uh
you know it's
I would suspect that with modern
engineering modern engineering design
methods that it really is possible to
make much safer nuclear uh reactors and
there's a question here about what do I
think of small modular reactors I've not
studied them in great detail I know a
bunch of people who are working on them
uh on on the face of it they seem like a
good idea I don't know the details
um and I really need to get going in a
second here
um
the uh
let's see
there are questions here about some
from spare parts about connection
between computational irreducibility and
extracting usable energy can energy be
mined with computation
uh that's a long story and it relates to
this thing called the second row of
thermodynamics which I've studied quite
a lot over the last 50 years I have to
say
um and that has to do with this question
of whether the energy of all these
molecules running around when something
is hot is that useful energy or is that
just heat that isn't useful how do you
line all those molecules up to be able
to turn a wheel to turn an electric
generator something like that and yes
the the story of kind of how do you go
from the apparent randomness of heat to
something more organized is a story of
kind of computational irreducibility and
yes it probably is the case that there
are places where you can make use of
energy more effectively by using
computation to know what's going on I
mean I wouldn't be surprised if there
weren't situations I uh many of the ones
we've talked about well in in the case
of wind energy uh you know usually the
wind is consistently blowing in a
certain direction over a wind wind
turbine but um if you were trying to
deal with you know something whether
just a little bit of wind blowing in
different directions but you have this
all these sensors and you can figure out
oh the wind is about to blow this way
turn the turn the kind of windmill in
that direction and you'll catch the wind
that way and then you know do this
computation turn in another Direction
catch the wind in that way that's a
place where you can use computation
effectively to collect more energy to
not have that energy seem like oh it's
wind going in random directions it's yes
it's sort of random but you can predict
it enough that you can kind of pre-wire
things to be picking up that energy all
right I
um
Reebok is commenting nuclear is not a
good thing until we have some way of
disposing of the waste products yeah
that that's a challenging thing it's
like where do you put the waste and um I
think the the main issue is
[Music]
um
uh what was it Yucca Mountain is the
place in the US where a bunch of nuclear
waste
um put sort of under the mountain and
the problem is when you do that if it
isn't deep enough it ends up being able
to get into groundwater and then it
seeps all over the place the
radioactivity can seep all over the
place and even this let's bury it and
put signs up that say you know that will
for 10 000 years tell people don't go
here after 10 000 years the
radioactivity will have dispersed so to
speak just by radioactive decay I kind
of like this is one reason I kind of
like this idea of just bury the reactor
a mile down because uh you know things
if you have something that's radioactive
and it's under a mile of rock it really
isn't going to do anybody any harm or
anything any harm and I'm not quite sure
why the depth of um
why it isn't the case that when one
thinks about nuclear waste disposal but
one isn't thinking about deeper
um you know just drilling things down
deeper I mean the ones were disposed in
the deep ocean disposed whatever I I
don't know why it's not just drilled
down deep in the Rock that's probably a
good reason for that but it seems like
sort of an obvious thing to do
um
but uh yeah also by the way I mean there
are there are skins for making nuclear
reactors where you can use many of the
waste products and that's I think one of
the things again I don't know
the details of these modular reactors I
should have paid more attention but I
think some of them make use of the waste
products
um and it's sort of a closed cycle in
the end I think yeah in fact in fact one
of them yes yes there's one type where
you seal it up for 100 years and it just
you know uses it internally uses the the
products of its of its um uh of its uh
nuclear reactions and so on
anyway I should stop there
thanks for joining me thanks for we had
a bit of a range of questions today
um and uh I see there were many other
interesting questions left over for
another time
but uh thanks so much and bye for now